[Music]
we're gonna chicken bring nachos this
seems a little irritated it's just super
uncomfortable and it makes you want to
get up and you're like deuces I'm going
to my room I thoroughly needed this
getaway to like I need to get out of LA
I need to get out of those people that
scenery I've been working so Ryan
arrives to Cabo
[Music]
he's one of my really really good
friends I introduced Ryan to Tamar and
she fell in love with him don't fall in
love Ryan he's like a big old teddy bear
Ryan is a great spirit he doesn't say
much but when he does and he's really
really funny
so you know I really love him to pieces
this broccoli was good CR saturated
without that butter
what's wrong we catch a regular butter
butter do you dig knees and ankles
butter get you why it's when I got gout
gout is a genetic disease I got it when
I got sick five years ago you can call a
rich man diseased poor manatee the Scout
hurts sometimes it feels like Tamar's
trying to be shady with me a little bit
did you know the air gives the victory
where's your pounds
god bless somebody you like talking
about me like a Jesus
[Music]
you